okay it is time for the big news making
prediction oh this is it
this is it okay
there will be
a significant
third party
presidential candidate that declares n22
this is not you declaring for president
right now all right this is not me
declaring right now but this is me
declaring that someone will declare in
20.
[Laughter]
boy the presidency someone's going to
run as a third party someone's going to
run as a third party and they'll
announce in 2022 they're going to
announce in 22. i even think
they're going to announce before the
midterms
wow well the midterms are in november
um but hear me out on this
so let's say you are a relatively
significant third party candidate
looking at this field
and you would see okay
joe biden 42 43 popularity on the other
side you have trump coming up
now what is your
cost benefit to waiting
until after the midterms
if you wait until after the midterms
then the oxygen will start going towards
both trump and let's say joe
and
it's going to be
potentially less advantageous to you to
be declaring later if you declare
earlier and if you return to the
bygone days of yang 2020
we declared in february of 2018
which would be
the equivalent of february 22. like
declaring in four weeks it's like
declaring in four weeks what are four
years for 2024 yes
so
why did we make that decision
well we didn't
have any
uh at the time we didn't have any uh
notoriety or
recognition
so
if you have some time you might as well
spend it stumping around new hampshire
and iowa going around in our case it was
the midwestern
mid-atlantic uh humanity first tour
uh if you were a third-party contender
you might as well get a jump on it
uh you
can use this time let's say you don't
hold elective office
uh you don't necessarily need to be
bound up to some you know geography or
role
so you might as well hit iowa summer 22.
so might as well declare a little bit
early and like get get some oxygen
though a third-party candidate doesn't
necessarily need to start out in iowa
new hampshire because they're not
running in the primaries so they can go
wherever they like they can just make
their case they can do podcasts so there
will be a third party candidate who
declares in all likelihood before the
midterms but definitely before your end
they're taking a page out of the andrew
yang playbook
yeah if you will and
uh
do i i also have a little bit of uh you
know like whispering in the wind uh
coming my way on this yeah i'm sure i'm
sure people
are hint
uh but that's good um
so one of the things we learned when we
were running for president was
um
i mean a whole bunch of things geez but
the big one was that the mainstream
media that normally drives narratives
they're now way more reactive right um
they uh
they didn't realize bernie was a thing
until he was drawing massive crowd they
didn't realize you were a thing until
you were already you know doing well um
so there's a world you're saying that's
an independent candidate can
go build up his or her notoriety on all
these alternatives and build up a
massive
following and then
who knows what that means come polling
time right yeah if you were a
third-party candidate and you ran the
numbers you'd be like okay if i wait how
does that play out if i go early how
does that play out
and
it's not just
the
the media i mean you you'd get
a chance to build and hone your message
you'd get a chance to build
relationships with various people
on the ground
right now because of the discontent
with both parties uh you know if you are
a credible third-party candidate you
could probably meet with like a whole
slew of people it'd be like well i
should at least see if this person's
legit
um so someone who's in this vein i think
is gonna
make the plunge or take the plunge
sometime this year right probably
before the midterms again that'll be fun
to watch
yeah do you think we'll get them to are
they going to run as an independent or
we can can you convince them to run as a
forward party
forwardist well i i'm saying
i'm saying that the person will be
running as a not as a as a non-democrat
non-republican got it who knows what
they run is cool yeah this is exciting
um will anyone else declare and i say
this because i wanna i wanna make sure
we remember this this is important never
forget andrew that john delaney
ran for president and aired a super bowl
ad in
2018.
you remember this i do remember yes um
and as someone who's run and
managed presidential campaign budgets
that is a horrific way to blow a few
million dollars of your presidential
budget
during the super bowl when your national
name id is approximately zero um
do you think any dems pull that pull of
john delaney not the super bowl thing
but declare really early that are
mainstream dams or are
on a major party line something like
that there was a story that came out in
politico this weekend about this very
thing
that will joe attract a primary
challenger yeah and this is one apparent
effect of buildback better not passing
is that the discontent
among
democrats is higher than it would have
been if they'd gotten this bill passed
now i happen to think buildback better
is going to be resuscitated there's
going to be a version of it it's going
to keep
moving forward over this next period of
time
but uh this political story there are
two things i'd like to say one the
political story is trying to manufacture
this
energy in a way because that loves to
try and you love this yeah they'd love
to try and set people into ideological
camps and like the the article was
framed as like is the left like going to
the left
had a relationship and he reached out to
this uh um but but they
what the article suggested i believe
correctly is that there is room for
someone to come and challenge joe
in the democratic primary now the
person's going to be very very far out
of the democratic establishment because
you can imagine anyone who's part of the
establishment does not want to
uh challenge joe you want me that guy
yeah you want to be that that that
person
but will someone if someone did decide
to run against
joe in a democratic primary
do they get 20
if they're credible i believe they do
maybe better
and this is like the fascinating dynamic
of that this primary challenge
is that
any legit
primary challenge to a sitting president
is very very damaging to that sitting
president uh regardless of whether it's
successful or not right and so this is
one reason why
um
obama was deeply concerned about bernie
challenging in
2012 not because he thought bernie would
win
but because it's very it's very very
damaging uh and so
if someone runs
against joe in the democratic primary i
don't think they declare necessarily
this year they might declare at the end
of this year after the midterms like
december 22
[Music]
and if they do run against joe there are
a certain number of people that will
support them in that endeavor you know
among the democratic primary electorate
just because they joe might not have
been their person
if you look at
for example iowa joe did not do well
there right so there are a lot of people
who supported someone else
most of them will now be on board with
joe because he's the president he's the
leader of the party
but will there be 20 of people
who are excited about an alternative
probably yes of course and so maybe more
like 20 could be low um and so
if you are a person who's on the outside
of the establishment and you see that
lane do you decide to take it
probably so probably someone does decide
to to challenge joe who's a
non-establishment figure
if you're a
main i don't know if that happens this
year though right if you're a mainstream
progressive if you're aoc or
elon or you know i remember the squad or
some of the bigger names it probably
doesn't make sense because you're not
going to win
it'll make it look like your move
because you're faced with the movement
it'll make you look like joe's squashing
your movement
but if you're
maybe a lesser-known progressive
um that wants to bump their name id out
there and fight for a lot of same
policies it could make sense because
then you bump your name id you'll
probably see it someone's gonna do it oh
boy man we're in for we're in for a fun
couple years well this is again why i
say i appreciate this year because yeah
we want to deal with what yeah like
after the midterms
all hell is going to break loose we'll
have so much time you know we have 11
months of relative sanity
oh boy but i believe someone probably
declares and and that person
who declares you know there'll be some
attention to them they'll make some
progress during that time i i
if i was advising that person i i think
that it's not a bad move having been
through it myself i mean especially if
it's not gonna be a crowded field which
is not going to be because i think
i mean maybe but um if joe says he's not
running but it looks like he's going to
be running then it probably won't be
that crowded um then you get more
attention anymore and you actually get
speaking time the debate stages you know
if you're one of the
three or four other candidates running
you know you know it's wild to just to
visualize this for a second that's why
i'm going to play this out which i just
said because i disagree with it by the
way okay lay it on me which is that uh
you imagine that joe's gonna have to
debate whoever this person is
oh you're saying it won't happen i don't
think i'd say it won't matter
like
i highly doubt it's a thing and like if
you were if you were the democrats would
you want your 81 year old president
to like come and like stand there for
like you know an hour and debate like
progressive tv we're democrats right so
play it out okay so it's the democratic
primary there's a bunch of people
running a couple people running you're
jamie harrison who's progressive right
he's head of the dnc you've got a woman
of color running against joe biden
you're gonna say she's silenced and
doesn't get to debate him that's a tough
spot for jamie right i don't know
they're gonna
like these are the like
yeah that that is that is an interesting
consideration
[Laughter]
but i i don't so just you know like i
don't think that there are
um there definitely will be republican
debates yeah those will be fun those are
always fun that they they drop the
gloves and the republican debates which
are hilarious the democrats are a little
more
subtly mean yeah and we can we can
return to what we think the republican
field will be
um but if you rewind to the
20 uh
16 race yeah when uh when trump beat
marco rubio ted cruz chris christie j
bush yeah like you can imagine sort of
like uh like a smaller version of that
because that field was open and trump
wasn't as dominant than as he is now
like there are going to be a bunch of
candidates who do not run against trump
because they they see much more downside
than upside yeah
and then look trump stops you in those
debate stages i mean we studied him when
we were preparing for our debates say we
want about donald trump he's a very very
good debater i mean debating is the
wrong term but
it's about the attention economy it's
he's great at keeping the spotlight on
him and telling you to shut up yeah so
if you're a third-party candidate i
guess what i'm suggesting to you zach is
they don't actually show up on any
debate stage
until
the general election which won't be
until
fall 24.
and right now the rules are that that
person would need to get higher than 15
percent right to make that stage but i
meant if you're a progressive you're
running
i think that person probably i i think
if if someone's a strong third-party
contender they probably surpassed 15.
they can get 15. yeah but if you're a
progressive
running the challenge joe biden on the
democratic ticket
would there be a debate and you're
saying they won't let them do it
that'll be fun to watch
[Music]
you